good afternoon everyone I'm delighted to
welcome you to this afternoon's science
technology and policy forum lecture as
I'm sure most of you know this series
was started last fall as a way to spark
dynamic campus-wide dialogue on
scientific and technological innovations
and discoveries and their potential
societal and broader policy impacts I
want to take a moment first of all as we
have our last lecture for this academic
year to thank you all for participating
and for your enthusiastic response to
this forum very much appreciate the
campus community's involvement in this
it's been such a pleasure to host this
series and to hear leading scientists
technologists and policy experts discuss
their fields and talk about the
importance of science and technology as
a critical public good I can think of no
better person to wrap up this year's
lecture series then our today's speaker
fail Oh max cook phase the head of
social behavioral economic sciences
director at the National Science
Foundation it's an influential arm of
the NSF that funds more than half of all
the nations university-based basic
research in the social behavioral and
economic sciences SBE as I'm sure many
of you know because many of you are
principal investigators for SBE that are
funded by SBE its mission is to promote
the understanding of human behavior and
social institutions and ways that
economic environmental political and
social forces that affect the lives of
people from birth to old age and the
ways that people affect these forces Fay
is on leave from Northwestern University
where she is a faculty fellow of the
institute for policy research and a
professor of human development and
Social Policy phase research focuses on
the interrelationships between
public opinion and social policy the
politics of Public Policy public
deliberation energy policy and the
dynamic of public and elite support for
social programs particularly programs
for older Americans such as Social
Security she's the author of many
articles and chapters as well as five
books including her most recent book
talking together public deliberation
political participation in America this
is a very timely and relevant book to
the current public discourse and
especially this year's election I'm sure
you agree on a personal note many of you
know that I served at the National
Science Foundation I had a pleasure of
overlapping with fayed NSF for a bit of
time and I witnessed firsthand the fresh
thinking that you brought to NSF during
a particularly challenging time for
government-funded basic research in many
areas including social science and and
economics she's an insightful and
thoughtful collaborator and I'm really
great grateful that she is able to join
us here and I'm very happy to call her
of course my friend before we hear from
Fei I just want to take a moment also to
thank Dean Krishna and also our
colleagues here in Hinds college for
coordinating phase visit and serving as
the college host for for Fay it is my
pleasure to invite faith Lomax quick to
the podium please join me in extending
warm
thank you very much it's absolutely
wonderful to be here at Carnegie Mellon
University we at the National Science
Foundation feel a very special affinity
toward Carnegie Mellon University it's a
wonderful University it's one of the
most interdisciplinary universities I
know but also we still feel a special
affinity because your president Subaru
soroush was the director of the National
Science Foundation for three years and
your Provost Barnum shahinian was head
of sighs computer information science
and engineering and because also we
support you to the level of 280 million
dollars so we have a lot invested in
this university and if somebody said to
me and it's not enough and so I agree I
have been spending time talking today to
a lot of faculty and I was impressed
before I came but these faculties they
have been great conversations and I've
ended the conversations by asking them
to tell me about grand challenges that
they think are important for the social
behavioral economic sciences and I have
to tell you that I have gotten some
absolutely outstanding ideas many ideas
that I'd thought about but some ideas
that I hadn't and so that was really
exciting so what I'm going to be talking
about today is opportunities and
challenges for the social behavioral and
economic sciences so the opportunities
of course are the great research that we
are able to support so I want to begin
by talking in general about the social
behavioral economics I
this in context the importance to
science and society and I want to talk
about sve research priorities but then I
also want to talk about challenges to
SPE research and there I want to talk
about 21 is the challenge of robust and
reliable science the problem in the
challenge of reproducibility and
replicability of the sciences and second
I want to talk about the issue of
communication and how we can do an even
better job in communicating the great
science that we do so at the National
Science Foundation you really can't
begin a talk about the context of the
work we do without paying tribute to
venir a bush and I think all across the
United States we in universities should
pay tribute to him he was the scientist
and engineer of course who headed all
the great science that took place during
World War two but when World War two
ended federal funding for science and
engineering was going to end too but the
neva Bush had a vision and he went to
President Roosevelt and he said we've
made great contributions during the war
we have to continue making great
progress in peacetime and so he wrote
this amazing book this report called
science the endless frontier because
science he sees is a frontier we stand
on the shoulders of giants we often say
but the frontier never ends because we
make one discovery and then there's
another and another and in this book he
said and it's up here scientific
progress is one essential key to our
security as a nation to our better
health to a higher standard
living into our cultural progress and
this is perfectly in line with what
began as the National Science Foundation
mission that has not changed to promote
the progress of science and in so doing
the broader impacts to advance the
national health prosperity and welfare
and to secure the national defense so at
SBE sometimes I am asked well tell me
about what is social behavioral and
economic sciences research in a nutshell
farnham actually said it but here's my
little heuristic model SBE research has
to do at its core with human behavior
and social organization and the way that
economic forces political forces social
and cultural forces and environmental
forces affect the lives of people from
birth to old age and how people can
affect those forces and what we also
show is this little model at NSF my role
as the head of the social behavioral
economic sciences is to help us invest
in great research that can result in
transformative science that advances
knowledge drives the US economy enhances
national security sustains global
leadership and improves lives so how do
we do that oh dear I just went much too
quickly we don't do it that quickly so
this is what you see in front of you is
our organizational model now I'm not
showing you this organizational model to
talk about every little thing in it I'm
showing it to you to give you a sense
the huge diversity within the social
behavioral and economic sciences I
actually think that we are one of the
most diverse of the seven directorates
we fund everything from archaeology and
anthropology in the division of
behavioral and cognitive sciences to the
science in engineering indicators
program in the National Center for our
science and engineering statistics so as
you can see SBE has three divisions
behavioral and cognitive science social
and economic science and the national
center for science and engineering
statistics our core programs in the
behavioral and cognitive sciences
division address questions fundamental
to human behavior and social
organizations what it means to be human
what are the origins of our human
ancestors where does stereotypes and
biases come from how do we express them
how does vision work what variables
influence learning questions addressed
by the core programs in our social and
economic sciences Directorate division
include questions like what factors
influence decision-making how when and
why do we cooperate or compete when does
conflict arise what variables impact
economic markets what aspects of an
organizational structure impact its
success and then we are really proud to
have the National Center for Science in
engineering statistics which is one of
the major 13 statistical agencies and
mcse s as we call it is the center that
conducts surveys to collect data on the
science and engineering enterprise so
what we do at SBE like in all of the
directorate's is that we conduct basic
research and it's for the broader impact
of creating knowledge that improves the
future so we sometimes get some
criticism about the science that we
support because we never know when we
fund a particular study what impact it's
actually going to have and each of these
little pictures here that you see behind
that picture is a story of some basic
scientific research that we really
didn't we knew what the Apophis ease
were but we didn't know what long-term
impact it was going to have and each of
these pictures represents just one of
many many stories we could tell about
this long-term impact so I want to share
with you just three little stories short
little stories about research that we
funded that's made a big impact and in
each of these stories didn't happen
overnight we funded the research and
then we funded more research and then we
funded more research and bam there was
an impact and this is happening I think
again and again so one of the people
that I was talking to today does
research on game theory and so he
noticed this well the example from game
theory began with Robert Wilson as you
can see in that circle up there who
applied game theory to the study of
auctions fundamental research on how
people bid against each other he began
his work in the 1960s with support from
the US Atomic Energy Commission and
later from social behavioral
I'm excited Directorate then Robert Paul
Milgram was Robert Wilson's graduate
student in the 1970s who was also
working on auction theory later on he
began focusing on the unique and
theoretical issues arising from
simultaneous auctions of multiple items
his work was also supported by SBE and
here's where timing and policymaker
interest played a key role in moving
basic research to applications with
real-world impact because Congress
granted the Federal Communications
Commission authority to conduct auctions
to allocate portions of the radio wave
spectrum which transmits sound data and
video across the country in other words
the radio waves that allow us to talk on
our cell phones and receive TV signals
and Wilson and Paul Milgram developed an
auction process called a simultaneous
multiple round auction a similar idea
was proposed by preston mcafee and the
FCC as the three of these economists to
work together and they designed the
first auction it was a huge success and
simultaneous multiple around auctions
have been used for dozens of spectrum
auctions in the United States and around
the world and these FCC auctions have
raised over a hundred and twenty billion
dollars for the federal government and
also help the rest of us by providing
access to cellular wireless networks now
it took a long time for this to happen
we were made a little bit of fun of in
the beginning what are you doing there
in SBE funding research on something
called you know game theory and auctions
but it's had a big impact so let me give
you another example
this example comes from psychologists
Hilary ifen vine who received funding
from the Social Psychology program at
SPE her work focuses on emotion
recognition our ability to recognize
another person's emotions via nonverbal
cues such as spatial expressions vocal
tones and body language now here's an
example of work again that we funded we
were criticized at the time we were
funded funded this work from the Science
Committee in the US Congress and said
what are you doing funding research on
nonverbal communication but in fact the
Army Research Institute has realized
that nonverbal communication is
extremely important in situations when
military personnel are in other parts of
the world where they don't speak the
language yet they have to interact with
local residents and so now the Army
Research Institute incorporates
nonverbal communications training for a
military personnel going overseas all of
them so this work and I won't go into
the detail has been extended to the
business community medicine to education
the same research that has had effect in
implications in at least four arenas so
here's the final example I'm going to
tell you about and this one again I was
talking to one of your researchers today
who does research in this area this
example has gone all the way to the
White House as you can see in 1969 we
funded the work of Daniel Kahneman and
Amos Tversky two psychologists who
introduced prospect theory it includes
some of you well know decision making uh
and helps explain why people sometimes
make decisions that seem really
irrational at least from an economist
point of view prospect theory posits
that gains and losses rather than final
amounts of wealth or what really sways
our decision it also posits that loss
aversion that the pain we feel from a
gain of the same magnitude that loss
aversion is not so important as games
and this work is a major building block
of what we now call of course behavioral
economics over the years sbes decision
risk and management sciences program has
sponsored research who have looked at
how prospect theory plays out in
different arenas and can be used in
different policy areas and in 1988 we
funded Colin Cameron and his
collaborators to study how people bought
part insurance of all things again
sounds strange but in a hypothetical
experiment they found that people tend
to choose whatever the default option is
if the high price option is the default
they'll pick that if the cheaper policy
is the option they all pick that the
point is that the way the choice was
framed results in consumers behavior and
these results it was discovered oh
really what happened in the real world
in late 1990s Richard Thaler and others
funded by the drms program studied loss
aversion that looked at people's
decisions with savings accounts they got
around the loss aversion problem by
having people commit to saving only what
was going to be in tomorrow's not
today's salary and as a result savings
rates for these people over time tripled
cameron taylor and cass sunstein
published a book called nudge which is a
popular book which espouses a lot of
this research and the ideas espoused by
these researchers have made it all the
way to the White House which now has a
behavioral sciences team shown in this
picture and in the late fall President
Obama issued an executive order called
using behavioral science insights to
better serve the American public and it
encourages executive branch agencies to
develop strategies for applying
behavioral science insights to federal
programs to evaluate their impact and to
recruit behavioral experts and social
scientists to join the federal
government to make this happen and they
also in this have encouraged federal
agencies to work more closely with the
science community to better use
empirical findings from the behavioral
sciences so these are just three
examples from all those little pictures
that I showed you to give you an example
of just some of the research that we
funded actually some years ago but how
it's had these long-term impacts we also
an SBE fund part of our core research
infrastructure we fund the big three
that we call you have heard about these
we've been funding these for years the
American national election studies the
general social survey in the panel study
of income dynamics and we also have a
number of other data and survey
investments that we we fund as part of
our research infrastructure do we need
to do more yes do we need to think
through some of the things
that we're already doing yes and those
are some of our challenges for the
future and of course I've already
mentioned that our third major division
in SBE is the national center for
science and engineering statistics which
is one of the nation's 13 principal
statistical agencies and the really the
leading provider of statistical data and
analyses for the US science and
engineering enterprise they conduct
every four years 17 periodic national
surveys and those are listed here and
two of the congressionally mandated
reports that they put out every year are
pictured here the science and
engineering indicators and the women and
minorities and disability differences in
our science and engineering workforce so
in a nutshell sve activities we have a
budget of 272 million dollars we have
about four thousand two hundred and
eighty four proposals each year make
awards of 1042 a success rate or a
funding rate of about twenty four
percent our average annualized awards
are not what we would like them to be
we'd like them to be much higher 137,000
we hold about fifty seven panels and we
support about 5114 people including 1858
graduate students and 733 undergraduates
so about seventy percent of our funding
in SBE goes to funding our core programs
so
and I showed our major programs and
divisions within SBE seventy percent of
our funding goes to our core programs
about thirty percent of our funding goes
to our cross Directorate initiatives and
for me one of the most exciting things
in the year and a half since I've been
at the National Science Foundation has
been some of these cross Directorate
initiatives coming from Northwestern
which is not quite is interdisciplinary
as Carnegie Mellon but it's a very into
dissonant disciplinary place so I was
used to interdisciplinary research but
at the National Science Foundation we
have we work across the directorate's to
fund some really important cross
Directorate initiatives and sve I'm
happy to tell you is central to all of
these because as the title here says SB
investigates the human dimension of
these crucial societal concerns whether
it's understanding the brain or risk and
resilience or innovations at the Nexus
of food energy and water systems or
inclusion includes as we call it it's
SBE as the Directorate that really
focuses on people and human
organizations that are at the center so
I just want to go through some of these
cross Directorate initiatives to give
you a sense of what we're doing when you
see the dollar signs there this is the
amount that we are investing in each of
these initiatives for fiscal year twenty
seventeen which begins October the first
but we are already investing in most of
these and what's interesting is
understanding the brain is a cross
directory
civ of every one of the directorate's
except for geosciences and so SBE is
working closely with biological sciences
engineering Computer Sciences
mathematical and physical sciences we
are all working together and the goal is
to understand the full complexity of the
brain in action and in context and the
question that we are really focusing on
in the SBE Sciences is to look at the
dynamic relationship between brain
structure and activity in human
cognition and behavior another direct
cross Directorate initiative that I'm
really excited about and that several of
us have talked about today is risk and
resilience critical resilient
interdependent infrastructure and
systems we have these very long acronyms
at NSF to get a lot in so Chris and the
reason we're thinking that crisp is so
important is because our economic
competitiveness and the societal
well-being in the United States really
does depend on the dependability
availability quality and the reliability
of our infrastructure systems but
they're too big risk to those
infrastructure systems one risk is the
risk from natural disasters hurricanes
tornadoes floods the other risk is from
people mistakes people make or terrorist
activities and so we are contributing to
this initiative to answer questions from
the social behavioral economic sciences
on how social and behavioral factors
contribute to critical interdependent
infrastructure risk so what we can do so
that those risks
happen and once the risk have taken
place how can we better inform people
how can we better take care of people
once things have occurred a third cross
Directorate initiative is the
innovations at the Nexus of food energy
and water systems infuse as we call it
the goal here is to enhance our capacity
to explore the interactions among food
energy and water systems and to
understand how these systems interact
with the social political and economic
systems so this is a third cross
Directorate initiative that SBE is
really at the center of a fourth
initiative is one that we are just
getting underway this year and it has
the longest acronym of all inclusion
across the nation of communities of
learners of underrepresented discoverers
in engineering and science and so you
can be very glad that we are just in
short calling it includes which I think
gets across the the meaning of it what
we're doing here is we're investing in
new research models and partnerships
that can lead to demonstrable progress
in meeting the challenge of broadening
participation and why is this such a
high priority for NSF it is because
women and minorities remain
underrepresented in STEM fields and in
the educational pipeline and so in order
we think to meet the challenges of the
future we want to open the door to more
people and we think that all of science
and engineering is going
to be benefiting from this the
contribution that the SBE science is
making here is to the science of
broadening participation and we are
going to be sending a Dear Colleague
letter in fact maybe that Dear Colleague
letter is already out and we want to
understand the positive and the negative
in fact factors that are impacting the
participation of women and
underrepresented minorities and we're
funding research we have funded and will
continue to fund research on these
factors things like implicit bias
explicit bias and stereotype threat so
I'm not going to go into as much detail
at all about the other continuing
investments in cross Directorate
activities secure and trustworthy
cyberspace or sexy I'm sure that when
Jim Barroso was here to speak that he
talked in depth about that one of the
things that I really like about Jim's
discussion of that is he always says
that secure and trustworthy cyberspace
is not technological problem and it
cannot be solved through technology
alone it's a socio technological problem
and we're going to solve this in
combination with social behavioral and
economic sciences we're also focusing on
the cyber infrastructure framework for
the 21st century science and engineering
and education and when I was talking to
faculty today I have to say I heard a
lot about the importance of data
infrastructure and data science and so
what we have got to be absolutely sure
in funding our cyber infrastructure
framework for the 21st century that we
have got to be sure that we are
answering the kind of questions that
came up today
so this is one of the things that I
found really helpful in my conversations
today about the importance big data
research infrastructure and how we need
to do really more in this area so the
opportunities that I've just been
talking about those are the
opportunities of the core research that
we fund the opportunities both in our
core programs and the research
opportunities in our cross Directorate
initiatives but we face some really big
challenges in the social behavioral and
economic sciences and I want this next
part of my talk to focus on what those
challenges are the first challenge is
the challenge of how we can better
communicate the value of the SBE
sciences as some of you perhaps recall
senator the former senator tom coburn
from oklahoma used to put out an annual
waste book of federal spending projects
that he thought were really wasteful
well since he retired in 2015 several
other congressmen have taken up his
mantle and we have the waste report from
Senator Rand Paul of Kentucky we have
the waste of the week from senator dan
coats Republican from Indiana we have
America's most wasted from Senator John
McCain of Arizona Jurassic Park from
Senator Jeff Flake from Arizona so we
are hearing in all of these reports
about the wasteful spending of the
federal government well there have been
three
chua waste books released in the past
eight months flakes Oklahoma senator
Langford's in Arizona Senator John
McCain's and together they feature 251
government programs or other funding
programs of these 251 programs 26 of
them are from the National Science
Foundation and eight of those were SPE
projects so you might have thought and
we might have thought when we first did
the analysis to see how many were SBE
that there were a lot more because it
sometimes seems to us from our seat at
SBE that we are always under attack from
Congress but I don't want to take this
lightly we needed to respond to those
but it's it's not as many as we thought
nonetheless we do continue to be singled
out and I want to share with you some of
the things that we are doing one of the
things that we do is when one of our
projects gets singled out in a report we
look carefully at the project what it
was about why it might have been singled
out and we write a simple response about
its intellectual merit in its broader
impact and I'm delighted to say that the
director of NSF France crdova often
goes to see the member of Congress and
explains the research so just for
example John McCain's research of waste
book had an example from a researcher
named Jody hermit who had developed a
virtual environment for her colleagues
to study how children cross the street
and this was this virtual environment
and they were studying how children
across the street to understand the way
children thought about crossing the
street the way drivers thought about
seeing or not seeing children and this
research was determined to be so
important that Toyota has taken the
research up and is using it in much of
its own research about cars in the
future and so one of the things that
we're trying to do is however we don't
want to just be responsive when there's
a negative thing we also want to be
responsive positively and I'll tell you
a little bit about that the second thing
that is a challenge that I'm going to
talk about is the challenge of robust
and reliable science so why is it so
hard to communicate the value of the SBE
sciences why is it so challenging part
is we have numerous audiences we have
scientists inside NSF outside NSF all of
you we have Congress and other
policymakers we have the public we have
journalists and so there are these
multiple audiences that we have to
respond to and we have to think about
how to communicate our story about
science the science of science
communication to these people also basic
research in the SBE sciences is
sometimes difficult to explain studies
sometimes appear kind of obvious or
maybe easily trivialized or mocked why
should we study nonverbal communication
why should we study auctions the
methodology is sometimes misunderstood
and as I showed in the three examples
before sometimes there's a really long
time lag
between the basic science findings and
application we don't see this so much in
computer science or engineering but we
do see this longer time lag in the
social sciences sometimes so what have
we done across NSF well first of all we
have established what we're calling the
transparency and accountability of our
ward abstracts and titles as scientist
you submit to us cutting-edge research
and your abstract shows that
cutting-edge research and you have some
terrific title but sometimes that's not
so clear to the lay public when they
look at that title and they look at that
abstract especially to members of the
Science Committee in the House of
Representatives when they have their
staff go through all of the titles and
abstracts of our funding to pick out
what might be problematic to them and so
what we are doing now under the title of
transparency and accountability we are
working with the p.i you might have had
this experience some of you to rewrite
the title and the abstract so that it is
very very clear and that it can be read
and understood by the lay public and we
also have an office of legislative and
public affairs who is making
arrangements for us to get out more and
more briefings on our research and what
the research is about and so we are
sending out that sheet and press
releases about the research we fund and
finally congressional briefings we're
having congressional briefings and we
are also
going to Congress and meeting with
members of Congress to talk about the
research that we're funding so just in
the last couple of weeks I've been to
the Appropriations Committee Science
Committee and I have been to see several
members of Congress to just sit down and
talk to them about what their agendas
are and to talk about what we're doing
and I always begin these by saying you
have many people who come to you as
people who have a big ask I'm not coming
with a big ask I'm really coming to tell
you about the great science that we
support and see so that you can see us
at sve at the National Science
Foundation is a resource when you're
developing a talk in Europe for your
constituents if you want to talk about a
particular issue if you want to call us
up and say what's the research that's
been funded we would be happy to help
and they actually seem to be doing that
and like that in the SBE Directorate we
have hired a dedicated communication
specialist we have a strategy we're
ramping up our social media presence you
can go on Twitter and find little tweets
about some of our research findings from
researchers like you and we are training
our program staff on their
communications responsibilities so
that's what we're doing in the area of
communications is it working we will see
I hope it's working I think that the
Congressional briefings and are going
and meeting with members of Congress is
making a real difference the congressman
Smith who's head of the Science
Committee really likes how we are making
our abstracts and titles clearer so he
can read them and see why it's important
so what's our other big challenge the
other big challenge is the challenge of
what we're calling robust and reliable
science you have seen a lot on the front
pages of the New York Times and on the
cover of the Atlantic and other popular
magazines that science is often not
being reproduced and replicated and this
is a problem so we task our advisory
committee with trying to look at robust
and reliable science our advisory
committee had a big to a three-day
workshop on this and ended up writing a
report you can see the title here SBE
sciences perspectives on robust and
reliable science and what they did is a
contribution is that they defined what
robust and reliable science is their
definition of robust and reliable
science is science that is reproducible
replicable and generalizable and they
defined each of those terms reproducible
another researcher can take exactly the
same data using the same methods and
reproduce the findings replicability is
a researcher taking a different data set
and replicating those findings with a
different data set and generalizability
is the extent to which we can generalize
from findings to other populations and
groups and at the end of their report
they suggested that we could do research
in sve on robust and reliable science
they were clear to say we not say
SBE should be taking this on because the
problem is a nsbe problem this is a
problem that has been said to be a
problem across the sciences and across
all of the directorate's to some extent
so they said we need research to figure
out what actually is the extent of the
problem to what extent of their
differences across the fields what are
best practices and then to the extent
there is a problem what are the causes
of the problem and which of those are
most important we should look at they
told us questionable research practices
the kind of incentives that there are in
universities to publish quickly and to
publish new findings and new date and
using new data rather than first to
think about replicating and reproducing
prior findings and so they want us to
understand not just research practices
but if there are incentives in the
academic culture in journal policies
funding agency policies we often hear oh
you know I that didn't get funded
because it's they're really just wanting
to replicate something that that we
already know well the fact is sometimes
we don't know and research needs to be
replicated and then finally the question
is to the extent there is a problem what
can we do to fix the problem and so
these are some of the things that we are
thinking about asking for research on we
want to strengthen sound
science across the science Enterprise we
want to support workshops on robust and
reliable research we want to support
research to replicate and generalize
pivotal disciplinary findings and we
want to support research to improve
robust and reliable science so these are
some of the ways that we want to tackle
this issue and I would just welcome also
your ideas about this so in conclusion
at the beginning I showed you a kind of
heuristic model that showed that we are
trying a nsbe Sciences to understand
human behavior and social organizations
I have tried to give you a sense of how
we are looking forward to continuing
sb's investments in basic research and
training to create the knowledge that we
thinks going to improve our future I've
tried to show you just a few examples of
how SBE research that we funded has had
important impacts we in the social
behavioral economic sciences Directorate
have funded the research of 52 Nobel
Prize winners in economics including at
least one winner every year since 1997
since 2006 we funded the research of 20
macarthur fellows or macarthur geniuses
is they're sometimes called and note
that we funded their research after they
won those prizes not when we knew that
they were prize winners we funded the
research that allowed them to do the
great research or for this prize they
won so moving forward we think this is a
really exciting time for the SBE
sciences and put
spe Directorate we are by far the
smallest of NSF seven directorates a
third the size of some a fourth the size
of budget of others but actually I think
we're central because we are the
Directorate that focuses on people and
we have research on people as our major
focus also we participate in many of
those cross Directorate initiatives
because societal concerns like risk and
resilience and understanding the brain
and cybersecurity really cannot be
understood justice technological or
biological or environmental problems
without thinking about people at the
center of it all as this slide shows so
we do think that it really does take
understanding people to unlock most of
the societal conundrums that we have and
we will continue to do that as long as
we continue to have the great scientist
here at Carnegie Mellon and elsewhere
who are sending us your outstanding
proposals and we appreciate everything
you do you are a really important part
of our sve and in SF community so I'm
happy to take some questions
geosciences sighs thank you I would like
to comment on the effect of geosciences
on SB they such as tsunami geothermal
energy and their titles stay near El
Nino they all causes changes in the
climate change and that can have an
effect on XP do you have any comment on
that absolutely I agree and we work with
the geosciences Directorate too it's
it's really the geosciences director at
the engineering Directorate and the SBE
Directorate that are working together on
innovations at the Nexus of food energy
and water and we're working on risk and
resilience so when I talked about the
they cross Directorate initiative on
risk and resilience one of the big risk
is risk from natural disasters as well
as risk from people and the risk from
natural disasters that Gio has asked us
to work with them on is how do we
communicate to people that there is
going to be a tornado or a flood or a
tsunami coming how do we communicate
that risk in advance so that people will
listen to it but once the horrible
natural disaster has occurred it's how
do we make a difference in helping
people in that situation because often
as you well know there is just chaos and
so people have to be helped and so
that's another way that we are working
with the geosciences but we really do
consider ourselves partners in those two
in several initiatives but with the
geosciences especially innovations at
the Nexus of food energy and water and
risk and resilience
several tens of millions of dollars
right absolutely sorry well recording it
so Faye when you presented the
organization chart on the right side you
had a interdisciplinary social and
behavioral research you had a separate
program or is that something you uncover
encourage and all your programs we have
three divisions and then there is what
we call in your right I didn't talk
about it SMA the SBE multidisciplinary
activities and that is where we have we
do a lot of interdisciplinary work but
that is where some of that
interdisciplinary work is really located
so for example that's where our science
of learning centers began as a cross SBE
activity that's where we have our
postdoctoral program that's where we
have the science of science innovation
policy program that's where we have our
undergraduate research experiences for
undergraduates we fund about 750
undergraduates so I really should have
mentioned that thank you hey thanks
again for visiting us and spending the
day with us really greatly appreciate
that you alluded to this in the course
of your presentation and during the day
as well this idea of where data sciences
and Social Science intersect and the
extent of it you see the need for new
studies in social science on account of
the fact that you have all these new
kinds of data sources being being made
available do you see that as something
that is part of SD ease sort of focus or
is do you see this as part of
the cross Directorate efforts that your
outline because I could see elements of
it in both these both both aspects of
your presentation wondering if you could
elaborate on that yes thank you well we
have to think about this is both within
SBE and across sv across all the
directories so the cross directorate
initiative that we have that i listed
under the for that i didn't go in two or
three that i didn't go into there was
one called SIF 21 cyber infrastructure
for the 21st century now it's there that
we fund projects on big data and we have
we are joint with computer information
science in looking at big data and
several of the other directorates
because big data we think needs both SBE
and computer science and engineering and
education human resources but we also
have within SBE a real interest in this
and within sve we have a program called
writer our idir and writer is research
investments for data intensive research
you know these acronyms but it's a
writer look it up and and writer is
providing grants we've got three grant
proposals that we currently funded and
they are much larger than the
traditional ones and we are saying to
our scientist SBE needs a better data
infrastructure come to us with your
ideas for data infrastructure pulling
together big data sets
that can answer important research
questions so writer is just within SBE
at this point in time but one of the
things I talked to people about today is
our grand challenges for the future and
we I really do believe that that data
big data understanding how to think
about data understanding what are the
important questions that we should be
asking with all this huge amounts of
data that scientists are getting can be
used and you made such an important
point to me you made the point that sb's
biggest contribution here could be
looking at the causal analysis so often
with this this huge revolution in Big
Data people are correlating big data and
they're just using it I hate to say some
scientists none of you here are kind of
using it mindlessly doing correlations
the big questions need to be there and
you made the point which I totally agree
with you is that the SBE contributions
should be in causal analysis
understanding big data but how we can
use causal analysis and develop better
methods to understand relationships
within that data and you're going to
send me some questions about that and
more information right
so let me echo krishnans appreciation
for coming it's great to have you and
that was a very informative talk so at
the very beginning of the talk you had
mentioned a few of the the surveys and
yes instruments that you've maintained
for a long time and you also hinted at
maybe new ones you are thinking of
developing I mean I in my perspective
there's been a huge game every time NSF
or some other comparable agency has
created right an instrument that's big
enough to create data by either in
social or natural science that
scientists can work on for a long time
so can you give us some hints about
where you were thinking of doing that
toward the future I can't because this
is something that we I mean it's a great
question we you know the big three are
very expensive the other ones that I
laid out time shared experiments tests
the Luxembourg income dynamic study
center all of these are really expensive
and what we have to be thinking about is
what's the best investment in our money
going forward and this is I think one of
our challenges and I welcome your ideas
about Dean Krishnan is got some ideas
he's going to be giving me and I'm going
to take those very seriously if you have
some ideas about what you think we
should do this is a time when we really
are thinking about the challenges for
the future because we have a little time
now because we don't have to develop
that fiscal year twenty eighteen budget
and I have asked every group I've spoken
with today what are what are the grand
challenges in the SPE sciences so if you
wrote up for me a couple of your
thoughts about what we should be doing
there and what we shouldn't be doing it
would mean a lot and we take it very
seriously hey one last and very quick
lesson
so you talked about the two challenges
and they kind of play off each other a
little bit and I was wondering if you
talked about that so for example the
incentives for producing novel insights
new contributions things that state
legislators about to move on or just
replicate already and how do you
communicate that value of the
replication well I think we are
communicating it by simply having an
interest in robust and reliable science
this whole theme is so important that
director of NSF France crdova held an
NSF wide symposium town hall meeting for
the whole day for all of our program
officers and Marcia McNutt editor of
science came and spoke because Marcia
McNutt really cares about data sharing
she really cares about robust and
reliable science she really said cares
about ethical research and so she spoke
and really challenged us across the
foundation and so SBE has taken up that
gauntlet and said it's not an SBE
problem per se but we in SBE can help
address the issue and if you look around
some of the SBE disciplines some there
has become a real renewed interest in
the importance of replication and the
importance of reproducibility and we are
figuring out ways that we can legitimize
the importance of reproducing and
replicating research before you go on to
that next big question thank you so much
for help me
Hank pay for a fabulous Preston boys